[Music]
[Applause]
this is the story of one of the biggest
corruption scandals of all time a fraud
that is estimated to have cost one of
the poorest countries in the world its
entire gdp for a year a story that would
not be possible without ingredients such
as unlimited expectations unbridled
greed and country risk today on
visualpolitik we are talking about the
tuna bonds of mozambique let's get
cracking
[Music]
in africa the forgotten continent the
last region of the world to join
modernity the first two decades of the
21st century were impressive poverty
began to fall sharply and most african
economies began to take off suddenly the
demand for infrastructure and projects
of all kinds made many governments of
the continent rush to the markets in
search of funds markets opened their
arms wide and the illusion of sharing a
part of that huge
wave of prosperity and you know what our
protagonist in this video mozambique was
not the only one of the countries
rushing towards the future but became
one of the most brilliant economies in
the whole continent institutional
reforms foreign investment tourism and
the discovery of a huge gas fields in
the removal river basin and mozambique's
northern coast bordering tanzania seemed
to paint a very promising future
during the first decade of the century
mozambique's economic growth was around
per year and that was before the
exploration of one of the largest
natural gas discoveries in the world was
launched to give you an idea while in
2010 the size of mozambique's economy
stood at around 10 billion dollars imf
forecast suggests that by 2021 it will
exceed 30 billion and 75 billion dollars
by 2025. yes it still made it a very
poor country but the expected evolution
was colossal however the reality has
been totally different
in 2021 the size of this south african
country's economy is less than 16
billion dollars and although things are
expected to improve the numbers will
still fall far short of the initial
forecast and even in recent years the
trajectory has been very different from
what was expected instead of good news
the country faced default a huge budget
adjustment and capital flight and the
burning question is why what happened
that suddenly caused the reality to be
so different from the initial projection
well visualpolitik fans the simplest
explanation has to do with a financial
operation a ruse that made this
country's economy face a terrible
nightmare check this out
the poisoned gift of the tuna bonds
the year was 2010. things were going
well for mozambique the national economy
had begun to take off and gas fields
promised unlimited profits however at a
certain point in that year a series of
meetings and agreements took place that
would mark the future of the country for
more than a decade executives from
privinvest a well-known french lebanese
shipbuilding company together with
executives from the swiss bank credit
suisse and senior government officials
put a business proposal on the table
at the time markets were embracing the
high yields of african bonds and
mozambique would soon be exploiting its
huge hydrocarbon deposits so why wait
the country could issue a huge amount of
debt to finance the development of new
productive sectors after all natural gas
will soon pay all of the bills well no
sooner said than done all parties joined
by the russian bank vtb set to work to
create a huge fishing industry in the
country
[Applause]
[Music]
the problem well the problem is that
mozambique's interests were never on the
table you see during the following three
years mozambique's government created
three public companies a matam
mozambique asset management and pro
indicus surprisingly the two main
shareholders are direct owners for the
ministry of defence and the intelligence
and security service yeah that's right
the ultimate shareholders of the
proposed fishing companies the fact is
that once formed between 2013 and 2014
the swiss bank credit suisse and the
russian vtb organized a round of funding
to move these projects forward in total
just over two billion dollars an amount
that may seem small to was until we
realized that this represented almost 15
percent of the country's entire gdp and
more than 20 of the entire foreign debt
in just three operations
[Music]
of this two billion dollars almost half
consisted of bonds placed on the
international market with a yield of 8.5
percent a profitability that made them a
huge success and the demand exceeded the
supply several times over they were the
now infamous tuna bonds however the
reality the stark reality is that it was
all kind of huge ruse to fleece one of
the poorest countries in the world
[Music]
for example the parties involved took
advantage of the fact that investment in
africa was in vogue in order to pull off
this bizarre operation the two banks
that handled the deal pocketed close to
200 million dollars in bank fees and
commissions that means that almost 10 of
all the financing went to the banks that
handled the deal totally
disproportionate
[Music]
what's more the prospectus and
feasibility studies were pure science
fiction for example international
investors were told that mozambique had
been catching around 200 000 tons of
tuna per year the reality is that
according to the national fisheries
office catches in 2015 between foreign
and domestic vehicles amounted to just
six thousand tons in addition revenue
estimates were based on the sale of tuna
at more than ten thousand dollars per
ton a totally unreasonable price on the
wholesale market but you know what
nobody cared you know investing in
africa was all the rage details were the
last thing on anyone's minds and among
the investors were such important
entities such as the portuguese
commercial bank and united bank for
africa
[Music]
the fact is that everyone got their
share except from the mozam beacons
themselves the issuing banks pocketed
200 million dollars the military spent
most of the funds obtained not on
fishing boats but on military boats and
equipment and the company that owned the
boats sold them at a significant premium
and of course politicians were not left
out in the picture ferraris rolled
royces bmws even a plane from france
loaded with 7 400 bottles of wine has
been documented and above all lots and
lots of cash
[Music]
in total audits have estimated the money
that went directly to bribes as totaling
up to 500 million dollars the tuna
companies were created not to operate
but as vehicles to milk the cow the idea
was that the gas profits would pay for
such a gap in the public budget that no
one would notice anything so the debt
was kept secret and not included in the
government accounts this is known as the
hidden debt the problem the big problem
is when the gas money didn't arrive
everything started to fall apart
the debacle
in 2016 when the wall street journal
published all the details about the debt
incurred the hysteria was tremendous
international donors and the imf itself
immediately stopped their contributions
plunging government revenues this in
turn meant the government was unable to
pay the bills then ta-da came the
spectacular default the collapse of
public spending the economic crisis the
flight of capital and the devaluation of
the currency foreign debt became
unpayable gdp growth plummeted
unemployment soared and almost a million
people fell below the poverty line
the tuna bonds were too cumbersome for
example as a result of this operation
the debt burden in relation to state
revenues increased more than six-fold
[Music]
to give you an idea according to the
calculations made by the centre for
public integrity in mozambique along
with the christian michaelson institute
in norway the economic cost exceeded 11
billion dollars the equivalent of their
country's entire gross domestic product
for 2016. a disaster that would punish
the country for years and that by the
way has become a new nightmare for
credit suisse a bank marked lately by
scandals such as the archivos capital
scandal that we already covered here on
visualpolitik in collaboration with
value school
[Music]
mozambique is reeling from the credit
suisse tuna bonds scandal the swiss bank
was fined
475 million dollars
the idea that this is over for credit
suisse is completely wrong there is a
lot of litigation in the english courts
at the moment and that is not going to
go away if anything it's going to go on
and on and on natasha harrison managing
partner of boys schiller flexner a u.s
law firm that has sued the swiss bank on
behalf of several creditors
the whole operation is now in court but
the damage has been done the collusion
of big banks politicians and
unscrupulous businessmen along with the
lack of attention to detail of
international investors caused a huge
catastrophe in one of the poorest
countries in the world so there you have
the cursed history of the tuna bonds
remember to pay attention to the details
to be wary of the lack of transparency
and legal certainty and easy profits
because they can end up turning into a
huge nightmare but now it's over to you
do you think mozambique should be dumped
with the repayment of this huge debt of
more than four billion dollars in total
plus interest how could this kind of
fraud be avoided leave us your comments
below and if you found this video
interesting don't forget to like and
subscribe to all of us here at
visualpolitik all the best and i'll see
you next time
[Music]
you